the Supreme Court on Friday dealt
another defeat to President Joe Biden
blocking his student loan forgiveness
program CNN reports in a stinging defeat
for President Joe Biden the Supreme
Court blocked the administration student
loan forgiveness plan Friday rejecting a
program aimed at delivering up to twenty
thousand dollars of relief to millions
of borrowers struggling with outstanding
debt the decision was 6'3 Chief Justice
John Roberts wrote for the conservative
super majority this will become an issue
in 2024 Biden can try to Galvanize
liberals by claiming the conservative
Court prevented him from delivering debt
relief to voters Republicans are
celebrating the ruling as a defeat for a
bailout plan
um republican-led States and
conservatives challenging the program
say it's an unlawful attempt to erase an
estimated 430 billion dollars of federal
student loan debt under the guise of the
pandemic Roberts said the Biden
Administration and Secretary of
Education rewrote the law
that it cannot fairly be called a waiver
it not only nullifies existing
Provisions but augments and expands them
dramatically
however broad the meaning of waive or
modify that language cannot authorize
the kind of exhaustive rewriting of the
statute that has taken place here I have
to tell you this is not surprising every
time we we talked about this for example
on the bonus show a David Pac-Man
membership costs six bucks a month yeah
Pat and I both said
this is shaky while we agree with the
policy
This legal basis is shaky and people
would call in during live calls and say
David should I stop paying my student
loans I owe nine grand should I stop
paying them because it might all get
paid off
and I said don't take that advice for me
it's not obvious to me that this is
going to survive
and it's not obvious to me that it makes
sense to allow interest to continue
accumulating while you wait for this to
work its way through the courts and
indeed this was the decision so listen
the Supreme Court has handed Joe Biden a
number of defeats by now the most
important the most important takeaway
and realization from all of this is
none of this would be happening
if Hillary Clinton had defeated Donald
Trump in 2016 and I know that there are
people in my audience who don't want to
hear this there are people who stayed
home or voted wrote someone in or
whatever in 2016.
under the guise that Hillary's just too
conservative for me yeah okay Trump's a
clown but not that different from
Hillary Clinton and there were people
like me and others who were saying
that's really dangerous were not just
pretending that the Supreme Court issue
could be a major issue it really could
look now Roe v Wade student loans I
can't even give you the full list
most of this stuff doesn't happen if
Hillary Clinton wins in 2016. with
rumors now of potentially multiple
retirements in the Supreme Court
upcoming
I am going to restate again and again
that the Supreme Court could be a major
issue in the next presidential term
and it is really important that we
remember that and we take 2016 as a
lesson as far as that goes so this is
the Supreme Court's decision this is a
loss for Joe Biden it is not a massive
surprise
uh but it is a reminder about the
importance of the Supreme Court and
we've got a horrible Supreme Court right
now I mean that it's it's the reality we
we have a horrible Supreme Court we will
continue following it we will see what
other venues there may be if any for Joe
Biden to do student loan forgiveness
there are he could have done it with a
different legal justification we've
talked about it before we will talk
about it again but that is the Supreme
Court's decision I love my Helix Sleep
mattress I've been sleeping on Helix
mattresses for years now which is why I
asked them to be a sponsor you actually
take their famous sleep quiz takes just
a few minutes to answer questions about
your sleep preferences body type sleep
position whether you have back pain and
Helix will match you with a mattress
that's perfect for you which is really
unique and helpful because a lot of
people don't know where to start when
buying a mattress I certainly didn't
their newest collection of mattresses
called Helix Elite come with a built-in
glaciote text layer to keep you cool at
night an extra layer of foam for
pressure relief and thousands of extra
micro coils for Best in Class support
and durability all of their mattresses
ship right to your door totally free
they come with a 10 or 15 year warranty
and you get 100 nights to decide if you
like it my audience also gets a whopping
20 percent off all orders plus two free
pillows go to Helix sleep.com slash
Pacman the link is in the description